[موسيقى]
عرفها جمهور الشاشه الكبيره كواحده من
حسناوات هوليود الاكثر جمالا حتى ان البعض
اعتبرها اكثر امراه جاذبيه على وجه الارض
فاصبح ذكر اسمها سكارليت جوهانسون كرمزا
للجمال لكنها لم تكتفي بذلك وصنعت لنفسه
ياسمين كبيرا جعلها الفنانه الاكثر اجرا
لعده اعوام فما قصتها ولدت سكارليت
انجلترا عام
1984 في نيويورك لعائله مؤلفه من ابن من
اصول دنماركيه وامه من اصول بلا روسيه
ولديها اخ توام يدعى هانتر كان جدها اجنار
جوهانسون كاتبا ومخرجا بارزان خلال
طفولتها واجهت اسرتها ظروفا ماديه اثرت
عليها لكنها لم تمنعها من حلمها باحتراف
الفن وهو طموح الذي دعمته والدتها
فالصحبتها مرا الى اختبارات الاداء
والمسارح حتى حظيت باول ظهور لها كممثله
على مسرح اوفراد واي وهي في الثامنه فقط
من عمرها ثم التحقت ببرامج للتدريب
المسرحيه ورغم انها تعرضت للاخفاقات حصلت
اخيرا على فرصه في الفيلم الكوميدي نورث
عام
ولتجدد مكانه على شاشه كبيره اجتهدت
جوهانسن في اداء الادوار الثانويه فحصلت
على الاطراء عن دورها في فيلم ماني اندرو
كما جذبت اهتماما نقاد عام 2001 بعد
ظهورها في فيلم غوست وورلد رغم انه لم
يحقق النجاح المرجوم شكل عام 2003 تحولا
في مسيره جوهانسن حيث حصلت على دورها
الاول بشخصيه شارلوت في فيلم لاست
اندرانسليشن وانا لا تعنه جائزه بافته
لافضل ممثله
اكتسبت جوهانسون شهرتان واسعه عن ادائها
ادوار البطوله فكانت نجمه عرفها الجمهور
في العديد من الافلام مثل لوسي وذا هورس
وسبيرال الذي توجه بجائزه افضل ممثله شابه
كما فازت باكثر من جائزه عن دورها في فيلم
مارس ستوري وبفضل الشهره التي حققتها في
فيلم بلاك كودو لقبت بالارمله السوداء
كنايه عن دورها فيه وحصدت عنه جائزه ام تي
في موفي انت تي في
في رصيد جوعانسون نحو 69 عاما والقاب
كثيره كافضل ممثله وافضل ممثله مساعده
والنجمه الاكثر اثاره واخيرا حصلت على
جائزه الجيل في حفله جوائز ام تي في في
العام الماضي 2021
واصبحت الفنانه الاعلى بين الممثلات
العالميات منذ عام 2018 حيث بلغ اجرها
العام الماضي 65 مليون دولار تقدر ثروه
جوهانسن بنحو 165 مليون دولار لتكون تلك
الحسناء الهوليوديه قد جمعت بين الجمال
والمال والشهره
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]